okay when the Music Stops please find a
seat thank you I call to order the
February
23rd 2024 meeting of Health and Human
Services oversight committee thank you
for those who have braved the one-in
heavy Frost to get here and um would the
clerk please call the
role representative Pearson here
representative King here representative
gray or I'm sorry Senator
gray representative Merchant
here representative
Weber representative Murphy here
representative McDonald
here representative
Edwards Senator
Rosenwald and senator
avard we have a quorum I believe thank
you Senator gray having broken the ice
two times ago with what he called an
Engineers joke uh when his staffer said
he wouldn't be here today I asked the
staffer to make sure should this happen
again that he forwards an engineered
joke at least because it's not part of
my genre but engineered jokes I guess
have a place so she said she would make
sure of it approval of the draft minutes
from January 26 you should have uh one
of the ways you know it's a draft as it
says draft on it and
uh if you haven't read it over take a
minute or two and
uh Mr chair if I may I will apologize
there are chunks that I omitted because
we were going through slides and and uh
Mr Lipman in particular walked us
through a number of slides and I could
not look at the slide and write at the
same time and the result is that my
notes for his walk through those slides
were completely incomprehensible so I
apologize for any emissions and if
there's any glaring emissions I hope
people will answer and yet you produced
three and a half pages which is wow I
know that that's not a comparison
assistant observation criticize somebody
who's willing to sit in and I was
say that's right and my thanks to
representative King that I don't have to
do it
again I'll make a motion to approve the
minutes second second let's continue to
look at them and you haven't yet it
is actually I may you may um I did show
up late because of the the weather but I
I was here
just it
it it does not at the beginning because
you weren't here at the beginning but on
page two under maternal mortality report
the second paragraph says uh
representative McDonald arrived at the
start of this part having been delayed
by vehicle accident tie ups and then you
will find at the very end end of the
minutes that um a quorum having been
achieved the December minutes were moved
second and accepted by a vote of four
and one
exstension at the very end which is
where we did them I if somebody would
prefer that it says um McDonald late at
the top that's fine but I I just did
them in real time you graciously
announced his entrance it's very
accurate yes although I don't know if I
want to be associated with maternal
mortality enough
but it's a sep paragraph very
exact only a
coincidence any uh further Reflections
on the
minutes
yeses on second page there's a typo if
it makes any difference where on the
fourth paragraph down the annual annual
report Wows
WS you sure she doesn't mean it was wow
it could have been could have been so
I'll leave that up to the discretion of
the uh clerk at the
time yeah the context yeah could either
way but she spelled naami
correctly that's because I started with
the excellent agenda given to us by Mr
Williams as my foundational document and
I simply used his agenda items going
forward word for the headings and that
was very helpful because I had all the
correct spelling of all the names and
didn't have an opportunity to mess it up
when I transcribed
it anything
else moved and seconded all in favor I I
opposed thank you and next
item the chair recogn I did that on
purpose the check chair recognizes
Deputy Commissioner Dr Marissa hen to
give us the
dhs's commissioner
update good morning morning so um at HHS
oversight last month we had um Justin
lucer join us from Hamstead Hospital
talking about children's mental health
and how we're expanding services to
those in need of acute Services it it
seemed um like we we owed you another
update on more on the adult side um and
our work to uh to eliminate emergency
department boarding since that's been a
huge area of work and there have been
many questions that this group has
raised relative to the important uh
topic of emergency department boarding
so wanted to give you an overview um and
uh seek your questions and input on that
topic um so first just I think everyone
is aware of what emergency department
boarding is but it might be worth um
just making sure we're on the same page
with with that definition so um there
are times when uh individuals uh are in
psychiatric crisis um and they go to an
emergency department because as we know
emergency departments are are open uh
24/7 they can't turn people away and so
as they seek services for one reason or
another um they find themselves there
and they are assessed um and in some
cases the uh Team there the social
workers the clinicians the phys Ians
determine that that patient needs a
higher level of care in an impatient
setting and as you might have heard
there is not uh the the number of the
the supply of impatient beds in New
Hampshire like across the country um has
not been sufficient in recent years to
keep up with the demand so what ends up
happening is a um a pretty awful
phenomenon a very traumatic phenomenon
for these patients where they sit in
these emergency departments sometimes um
in windowless rooms sometimes even in
hallways um for hours days waiting for
an patient psychiatric bed to open up
and if you can imagine um this being uh
among their most challenging darkest
days for themselves their families um
the experience for for the uh the
patient and their loved ones and for the
hospital staff is um has many negative
Ripple effects um and during that time
often times their already poor mental
health deteriorates much further so um
as a department we started working on
the issue of reducing this burden of
folks waiting for beds um with the
release of our 2019 10year mental health
plan however we realized there was a
need uh to accelerate a number of key
elements of that um given the continued
uh numbers that were just unacceptable
given the concerns of many stakeholders
and Advocates um and given the impacts
of covid on societal mental health we
were seeing an increase as opposed to a
decrease in some of those boarding
numbers and as you might have heard
there was also the state was being sued
um by a group of hospitals to do
something about this and so that added
um a little a little bit more um oomph
to our efforts and so we decided rather
than trying to solve this alone as a
department we really needed to come
together with an array of stakeholders
including the who were suing us um to
say what can we do together we all
accept that it is um we all accept that
it's unacceptable for any patient to be
um waiting for longer than uh you know
some reasonable period of time to get
into a a critical level of care and just
as you would never deny a patient who's
in uh cardiac arrest and just have them
sit in emergency department it should be
no different when it comes to a
Behavioral Health crisis so we formed a
team and last year um we first realized
we need needed to diagnose the issue in
a new way because just building beds
hasn't cut it in our state and in other
states and so on the two-page document
that you have you can see essentially
reviewing what other states have done
that has made a difference reviewing um
uh sort of best practice and then
looking at New Hampshire data we
assessed the situation to involve three
key drivers those drivers are um excuse
me could you show us what this do sorry
colorful one yep thank you
um so the yeah yeah the key drivers of
the problem um were first uh what we
have termed front door issues so this is
sort of why do people go to the
emergency department in psychiatric
crisis in the first place it may be that
they have experienced um a life event or
a deterioration in their mental
well-being but it may be because we have
not provided enough options in the
community to to prevent and to to offer
them another Avenue for for services and
by we I don't just mean the state I mean
I think society as a whole and so front
door issues kind of what are the drivers
that actually lead to someone being in
such a situation of feeling unsafe to
themselves or others that they need to
be in that restrictive clinical context
um are the first set of issues the
second um core set of factors are the
ones that we've tended to uh focus on in
the past which is really our impatient
Supply but also our coordination issues
um so right now if you or a loved one is
sitting um in an emergency department in
New Hampshire needing a psychiatric bed
that hospital traditionally has been
calling around desperately to all the
hospitals that have psychiatric beds
trying to find you a place turns out
that is not a very efficient way to go
about things um and it can create
situations of just a a very
uncoordinated very fragmented I won't
even call it a system it's um it's sort
of a a good luck um you know uh way of
navigating things and so the actual
coordination of the beds that we do have
in addition to the overall number number
is the second um factor and then the
final is we have a phenomenon where
patients can sometimes end up staying in
psychiatric hospitals longer than they
need to because there's not um
appropriate plans and services and
supports to help them safely return to
the community so that could be things
like lack of housing that could be lack
of other social and um Human Service
supports um and so forth and so that
would essentially you can get people who
um are taking up beds from those who
newly need it because of those back door
issues so that's kind of how we bird's
eye view looked at the issue and then to
fast forward through a lot of work and
Analysis and meetings and um research
that went on we ended up saying okay we
can't do everything but let's find six
things we can do as a state working in
Partnership that will move the dial and
so and that that are aligned fully with
our tenure Mental Health Plan and so
that's what I want to just give you a
brief update of what those six core are
are um we don't pretend to think that
this is everything we don't pretend to
think that any one of these is going to
be a silver bullet but by addressing all
of these we can start to move those
three factors I walked you um through
and so just to go um on to the second
page and to bring you to present day uh
for around what has been going on here
again in in concert and through a very
structured governance system with New
Hampshire Hospital Association Nami the
Community Mental Health Centers Patient
Advocates people with lived experience
we have we've uh cast a wide net in
terms of of those who are steering this
um ship so I'll briefly go through these
um and then um and then seek your your
questions um so starting kind of from
that front door and moving through the
impatient and then back door the first
has been embracing a model that um
representative Pearson as we've gone to
a couple uh National events have heard a
lot about um it's really The Cutting
Edge for Community Mental Health the
certified community behavioral health
model essentially building on the
Community Mental Health Center as
they're known today but integrating
Services across the lifespan so kids and
adults um not excluding substance use um
from the equation and then engaging in
alternative payment models that make all
of this more sustainable and more based
on um performance of of the center so
long story short we received a planning
Grant We have basically the entire
States network of Community Mental
Health Centers engaged Nami brandise
others working with us and samsa the
federal um subance Abuse and Mental
Health um Services Administration
working with us to expand this model in
New Hampshire um and already have two
ccbhcs prime to receive patients um by
next spring and are on our road toward
um being eligible for a federal
demonstration Grant so it's not going to
fix things overnight but Most states
have seen an increase in about 25%
somewhere between 15 and 25% the number
of patients they can serve so this is
sort of a door to that um access
hopefully diverting people from needing
emergency department care when their
needs have uh
exacerbated the second is um having an
expanded array of options when people
are in crisis so as you might be aware
um we currently in New Hampshire a year
and a half two years ago launched both a
phone and chat service um that is part
of the 988 umbrella of services so that
someone who is experiencing a
psychiatric or Behavioral Health crisis
has um have folks they can reach out to
who are highly trained there's also
mobile crisis teams that can be deployed
to go to somebody's um home Community
School to reach them um and this is the
third leg on that stool so in addition
to the phone chat the uh mobile crisis
this is a physical place to go that is
an alternative to an emergency
department to get stabilizing services
so picture sort of an armchair type
setting you can be there up to 23 and a
half hours just shy of an overnight um
and um often times avoid the need for
psychiatric care by getting that
specialized Services well in crisis so
we have two of these um community- based
crisis stabilization centers opening um
and the first is coming online this year
and uh and more to come and an array of
federal technical assistance um as well
as State
dollars third so now we're moving oh
please yes go ahead thank
you sorry um I know you wanted questions
at the end but I'm really confused at
this point between
uh one and the certified Community
whatever BH is clinics and the uh
location based crisis centers and and
you said two of the first ones were
coming online and then I I've gotten
confused about what those are and
whether they're two different things or
the same thing yeah no problem it's a
lot of acronyms and similar sounding um
terms so it's uh so the the the first
one the community behavioral health
clinics are essentially building on what
is what you know now as the the
Community Mental Health Centers it's but
they're in addition to well they're
actually it's a it's a transformation of
those existing services so of those
existing centers so they are basically
growing their services who they can
serve how they serve and their financial
sustainability to become certified as
ccbhc so it's sort of uh think of it as
you know our current community
behavioral health system uh on steroids
um and so a huge amount of growth
happening there the crisis centers the
second one is really meant to be a
specific setting for people who would
otherwise um likely need to go to
emergency department because they are
not safe to themselves or others so it's
short-term Subacute stay um not meant to
be like a you know it's not it's sort of
that midpoint between an emergency
department and a impatient psychiatric
bed but often um negating the need for
either by by better serving people in
the midst of that crisis that um psych
psychotic break that you know life event
that has happened that has really shaken
them to their core so basic deescalation
is what deescalation stabilization
medication management so and referrals I
mean I think the idea isn't that it's
sort of a a you know one stop and you're
done but you're actually if you're not
already connected to outpatient
resources so you could actually come
into the crisis center and then be
referred out to a the first row the um
the community uh Behavioral Health
Clinic which is more of an outpatient um
ongoing care
does that help yep thank you very much I
appreciate it of course so now moving
into that impatient zone of having the
right number of beds coordinating
efficiently among those beds um we are
terming this feature care traffic
control um because we want to sort of
evoke that notion of a centralized
service for making sure people or you
know kind of air traffic control uh uh
metaphor like are getting to the right
place and that there's a sense of of
centralized accountability for them so
what this amounts to is a the hospitals
and we have our own work groups and um
collaborations going on in this the
hospitals are at the table New Hampshire
hospital is at the table the community
entities are at the table saying here's
going to be a standardized process
whenever one of these patients is
involuntarily admitted or invol in need
of involuntary Services we're all going
to fill out the same paperwork we're
going to send a centralized packet of
information to New Hampshire hospital to
agree with us that we all that this
patient needs to have their uh needs to
be hospitalized involuntarily and then
we're going to work together to say
here's how many beds I have here's my
Staffing situation much like during
covid the hospitals came together to to
share information and to sort of work as
one system this is the first phases of
moving toward an actual centralized
Statewide system um and so it's we soft
launched in January by centralizing as I
I said that that documentation and
process of um submitting the the uh
justification for involuntary
hospitalization we're now moving in and
we hired four positions actually at New
Hampshire hospital to actually
facilitate all this communication and
and data exchange and now we're moving
into the more meaningful and challenging
work of how do we actually uh
acknowledge and coordinate when we have
a referral so that if this patient's
sitting at the Elliott and this patient
sitting at conquered Hospital we
actually have a Way in real time of
sharing information and getting the
patients to the right place at the right
time so it's a huge lift um Mo anyway we
can talk more about it but it's but it's
a major feature of how we make use of
the beds we do have while we expand that
array and that brings me to the fourth
one which is actually expanding what we
call Designated receiving facility beds
this is a designation that is giving
given by the state um recognizing that
these hospitals um including New
Hampshire hospital are able to accept
involuntary admission
but basically think of these as
Behavioral Health beds um in our public
system so there's a number of ways that
we're going to increase the supply of
beds to be more right-sized with demand
um one is getting New Hampshire hospital
up to its full capacity of 184 by the
end of this year um another is setting
up for the first time the northernmost
believe it or not um drf beds at
Dartmouth um allowing Dartmouth to have
a five bed drf unit and then finally you
may have heard about this major
behavioral health project that the state
is providing 15 million towards that
solution Health um is setting up in
Southern New Hampshire so this will be a
new behavioral health facility um and
the state is providing funding but also
um having very special requirements to
make sure that it is um serving the most
vulnerable in our system for the record
where in Southern New Hampshire so this
is now public the the the proposed site
is in londondary okay and they've
approached that's thank you yeah and the
lenon Jerry Town Council and all those
processes are unfolding so happy to
provide more updates on that um second
to last on the list is thinking about
that back door so how do we make sure
that we're getting people great care in
an appropriate impatient setting and
then we are getting them returned safely
smoothly um with support to the
community thus um hopefully preventing
their need to return to an impatient
setting while opening up those beds for
others who will need it
um so there's a number of things going
on here um one that's been quite
meaningful is we have patients um at New
Hampshire hospital who have been there
for many many many days like sometimes
hundreds of days because the type of
care they need is in a nursing home
level of care so they both have a
psychiatric level of need that has been
treated but they also are um
experiencing uh medical fragility as
well and for that population we were
able to partner and help fund through
straford County nursing home um a
appropriate far less restrictive
Community oriented Services thus getting
them into a much more appropriate and
therapeutic setting for their needs than
New Hampshire hospital recom uh uh
represents so that's one example there's
also a number of um contracts that we've
signed to to start uh other residential
transitional housing programs that are
listed here so housing not surprisingly
a huge determinant of uh health and
mental health and a major factor when it
comes to not just helping patients
discharge but but preventing them from
needing that acute level of care in uh
in the future hopefully where are the
two uh five bid programs about to start
at that is a really good question and I
don't have Julianne here it um I'm gonna
have to get back to you on that one I
I'm pretty sure I know but I don't want
to misspeak
so um and then the last one is landlord
incentives so this is actually um we
just got this passed um at uh at
governor and councel so there's a really
neat program that gr Granite United Way
runs to help landlords become more
comfortable um accepting as tenants
people with mental illness recognizing
that um that process of being a landlord
to someone especially with a serious
mental illness requires knowledge
flexibility Financial reserves in the
event that someone breaks something um
and it requires a team of community
providers to be working to keep that
person stable um this is a population in
an already crunched housing environment
that is often disproportionately um
challenged when it comes to getting into
housing so we will have 25 patients
moved into stable housing through this
expanded partnership with granite United
Way um by the midpoint of this year so
taken in whole these are all again this
isn't we're not trying to claim that
this is going to um any one of these as
sort of a silver bullet what we're what
we're attempting to do is to
dramatically change the the way that we
think about serving people with mental
illness who are ending up in our
emergency departments in hopes of
dramatically reducing and eventually
eliminating um any of those uh those
experiences of boarding so that's that's
a plan um a lot more coming at you and
updates for you as we work on our public
facing data dashboard but um but that's
the
latest representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I'd be very
interested you may not have it in the
data dashboards that you're talking
about may help but you know we hear the
numbers daily on the boarding crisis
ands and I would be very much interested
to know what the numbers are for the
back
door Log Jam because um it it does
contribute in all the ways you've
recognized and I suddenly realized that
we have there aren't as many loud
metrics about that
and um that's so that's one thing I
would just love to see if you have it
and then the other question I have is
about uh a little more about the
psychiatric nursing home issue I know we
have the Glen Cliff home um and so now
we have the partnership with um
Strafford straford
um could you tell me a little more about
the the straford partnership because I'm
I'm thinking click click click uh about
my own nursing home and the issue there
of course is Staff rather and under
utilization but it just it it hurts me
that we have facilities available that
are
underused when we have patients in need
in so many different Health
Care
niches um and it also kills me that um
chesher Med used to have either a six or
an8 bed psychiatric unit and when their
psychiatrist retired they couldn't find
another one and and the governor yelled
at me you're telling me there is no
psychiatrist in cheser County well I
don't know whether there is or isn't but
we couldn't find one yeah and actually I
should mention the the there's also a
whole specialty field of geros
psychiatric care that um when we made
the agreement with solution health for
their new facility includes um the the
expansion by 16 beds they already have a
a small psychiatric unit at the Elliot
Jos psychiatric unit but this will
expand that um by I think another 16
beds so um so in terms of the the
straford county Arrangement and there
are others here who can speak to it more
so um Glen Cliffe is a a key part and a
you know one of the state run 247
facilities for for individuals in need
of both psychiatric and nursing home
care but there's a weight list for Glen
Cliffe and Glen Cliff doesn't always
always make the most sense if you've
ever visited it and if you haven't
highly recommend it it is a stunning
former tuberculosis sanatorium on the
side of Mount musak it is it is a
remarkable place that is as New
Hampshire as it gets and it's also very
remote and so um one of the things
that's been nice with straford county is
some of the patients who have been able
to discharge from New Hampshire hospital
have roots in that area so not only are
they closer to Natural supports but the
part of the model what we're financially
supporting there is a regular
reassessment so that they don't if they
can move from a nursing home to an even
less restrictive setting that is the
expectation um and the the design so our
hope is um not that Glen Cliff won't
continue to play an important role but
this is diversifying both geographically
and in terms of the number and array of
um of beds available uh as an
alternative to to an impatient the most
restrictive setting there is
representative Murphy yeah thank you uh
Mr chairman and looking at number three
the drf beds the five beds at uh at
Dartmouth yes is that the end result of
the negotiated um um government mandate
that they accept patients and are these
beds in Lebanon the beds are in Lebanon
we actually toured the the site um
recently I don't um this was not a
requirement I I think I know what you're
referring to because there were previous
deals that Dartmouth was involved with
there was a um the merger between uh
exiter hospital and I'm going to get it
wrong who their partner was did have a
requirement of 10 drf beds so that's
actually we don't have it listed here
but we are tracking the exiter project
as that was a requirement um per the
Attorney General um charitable uh uh
review of that uh merger follow Mr
chairman yeah follow up just a have we
ever in this whole you know having lived
through many of these in um emergency
room uh housing of these patients have
you are you aware have there been any
mtala violations in the state with any
of these patients U over the course of
the last few years it's a good question
and I don't uh it's you're not the first
to raise it and I don't know the answer
so let me um let me get back to you on
that okay thank you
yeah representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking the question also I want to
commend the department for putting
together I think a well thought through
uh plan of
action as we monitor through this going
forward being in the committee what are
your thoughts of having sort of a
metrics dealing with the front door
issues the impatient Supply and
coordination and also the backd door
issues so we can sort of track progress
and how we're doing and try to
understand of these three components is
there one still having significant
issues that we have to address maybe
legislatively so what are you thoughts
on trying to provide to this committee
and ultimately to the legislative body
sort of a tracking mechanism to how
we're doing very reminiscent of your
question about Hamstead last meeting um
for which I think data is is an
essential um part of how we're uh going
to manage the challenges at hand so the
answer is um we're completely committed
to that and in fact the data work group
that again is formed not just the
department but also we have um data
analysts from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association from the Community Mental
Health Centers from Nami um the intent
is to be fully transparent so ideas like
representative Webbers around
um for the you know emphasizing that
back door issue will be part of that
right now if you go to our website there
is a list you can look at the drf the
the facilities that have drf beds right
now and the number of people that are
waiting you can also see a a snapshot of
Hamstead but it's not a very it's not
the level of depth and it's not
connected to tracking progress and
challenges on these initiatives as it
needs to be so we expect in the next two
months or so we should have a prototype
and would be happy to share um the
website but also bring some visuals here
thank you yeah representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair uh thank you Dr H for
taking my question I I'm I'm I saw this
uh the commissioner was over at the
governor's commission so so I saw this
get the double of both of us yeah but
it's such an important topic I'm really
glad I I was thinking about um the
visual information aspect of this and
and what what my mind would like to have
is uh your classic uh graph that uh from
left to right is time and I'd like to
see you know two two numbers tracked so
we could look at the lines over time and
one line uh to me would want to be um
the number of drf beds under Central
visibility mhm uh which by the way I
think is great that you guys have
Central visibility now that was a huge
part of solving this problem so that's
great uh and then the second line
obviously would be uh you know the
number being boarded and I know that
that boarded number changes you know
hourly but you know if you could just
pick a predict or a stable point in time
to where we could at least have some
comparison as we look at it over time I
mean it would be so great just to look
at one graph and go okay there's our
capacity there's our you know the other
line is we we're solving the problem or
we're not um so so yeah no we're we're I
think that's exactly the the trend data
that we have in mind we actually in
hiring the four care traffic control
positions um one of those is a business
systems analyst um to very much increase
our sophistication around what we
measure also um as you may be aware we
are required to provide um quarterly
reports to the judge who ruled in the
decision um in which the hospitals
resuing the state and so we have to uh
she has asked for that data to be
generated anyway so we're we're totally
on it followup followup so so you just
opened the segue to to my other question
was I I don't know Mr chair because I I
haven't been around much how frequently
we're getting the these boarding updates
but if the department has to generate
something quarterly uh uh would it be
okay if we asked to get just get a
courtesy copy so we could be um tracking
along this is this is be okay for you to
ask this this would this is a strategic
problem and I think we really need to
have our eyes on it yeah we are happy to
provide um those quarterly updates as I
said we are in the process of
prototyping our dashboard so right now
actually we've um the courts asked us to
provide more data which is part of
what's informing how we go about doing
exact L this build so uh I don't I don't
believe there's anything confidential or
proprietary about what we're providing
to the courts I need to check on that
with our chief legal officer but we
could provide you a copy of the
quarterly reports or direct you to you
know so I I think in spirit the concept
makes total sense and I want to make
sure that you're not you're getting the
full spectrum of data regardless of
whether it's something the courts are
requesting so okay so that so that makes
me a little uncomfortable I'm trying not
to ask for additional information or
more work on the
part dual use send it to us both so let
me answer it this way we haven't
determined exactly the format that our
reports to the court will take it
depends on they they have to ask for
specific updates in a in a slightly
narrower version than just what we're
what we're terming Mission zero and so
the answer is we can provide you with
exactly the same data that we provide to
the courts and I also want you to be
aware of some of the wider dashboards
were doing that they may not be tracking
per their judgment as closely all right
and and I just had one more one more one
more uh would you remind us of the date
that the court said we need to be in
compliance I think they only gave us a
year and that's not really possible and
then the other date would be uh in your
best projection where do you think we're
going to be in compliance are we going
to need a total of two years is this a
three-year problem what what what are
you thinking about when we're going to
be in court compliance yeah so can you
even answer that because of I can't
really answer the second one just
because I think we have to be very
careful what we say publicly relative to
ongoing litigation what I can say is the
and this is of course public the the
agreement that was come to um uh set a
date of May 2024 so this coming May um
and we are doing we're working
tirelessly at a at a i I think at a
speed and with a level of resources
thanks to the legislator's um budget
Appropriations and so forth to to do
everything we can to get as far as we
can so thank you yeah representative
Weber I was just visualizing uh
representative Edwards graph and
thinking that uh my My Backdoor
statistics would be very helpful as a
third line on that graph um because he
has the front door statistics the the
beds but uh knowing who's waiting by the
back door to get out uh would also be
helpful in terms of a metric of how
we're doing to getting people to be in
the right place that's that's entirely
Our intention so I be careful I may
recruit some of you to be in our data
work
group representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman I have a
comment and a question um comment is I'm
I'm delighted that um the 20 bed
facility you said is going to go to
London Derry that's that is the plan
right now they received um prelimin they
had to change zoning in this particular
industrial area which it was uh
unanimously determined at a meeting in
December so that the town has been very
welcoming by all accounts now they're
going through all the permitting and
construction and everything and they're
on District so okay yeah yeah there's
been a couple articles um in the Press
about it but it's uh it's been more you
know if you're at Town meetings it's
been coming up there is it up near the
airport you said industrial area don't
want to get it wrong but let me send you
the um specific uh location I I I I
don't know the geography of L well
enough is it closer to his house in
Hamstead hospital is to mine I don't
live in I don't think that I can say
probably not with
confidence um but but yes you get to my
question
um expansion of the certified Community
me behavioral health clinics um you
indicate nine are those County based
Hospital based or are that I assume
they're geographically disposed yeah
they're geographically distributed I I
actually it's looking to see if there's
others who who you know it's a there's a
there's a network of them um but whether
it falls into county by county I does
not okay Chris can more history so I was
wondering if one County was getting left
out or
something Chris santinello associate
commissioner our Mental Health Centers
have a catchment area that roughly
follows our district office catchman
area so some some are County some cross
count line some are multiple
counties now there's are there still 11
go ahead Miss sure uh there's when I was
with the Department there were 11
district offices so are there still 11
catchman areas there's 10 but 10 Mental
Health Centers 11 district offices okay
so which area isn't being covered based
on
that we'll have to look at it because I
think some of the some of the district
offices there may be more than one in a
geographic area oh okay right um by the
way that gave me a second to look up the
location for the five first five bed
property which is Newport by the way the
second one um hasn't is still in
negotiations but Newport will be the
first one for that additional um five
bed uh uh transitional housing
y thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your report thank
you Medicaid Program Medicaid adult
dental and Medicaid expansion
updates Henry Lipman and Dr Sarah
fenny
okay um good morning thank you very much
for um giving us time this morning to
report on the Medicaid adult dental
benefits as it stands today almost one
year into the program um if you look at
the handout uh page two we can start
with um service utilization and
administration I'm happy to say that
between April 1st and today we have
served um just shy of 11,000 unique
members
um and then the the chart to the left
shows our claims counts and the members
seen counts by month I will caution that
January and February we still have um a
runout time so I would look at those
numbers with a grain of salt those will
definitely change by the next time um we
have a report for you and will
increase we have seen um a steady
increase in the number of uh uh claims
that we're seeing and the number of
members seen which I'm very happy about
um in particular we have had 26 denture
services delivered between April 1st and
December
31st what that means is that um any
individual either denture a full denture
or partial denture counts as one service
so for example if someone had a full
upper denture as well as a full lower
denture those would actually be two
Services um and as I had mentioned in uh
previous reports
we're going to slowly see more and more
of those um Services provided that is
not something that's one simple
appointment there's a number of
appointments um between start and finish
of the service and when the claim
actually comes in so there again there
is a bit of a lag between the time um
that the plan was implemented and we see
that more of these services are coming
in um moving on to uh our Network
dashboard as of mid February we have 160
unique providers in 109
locations out of those 160 unique
providers we have 21 unique oral
surgeons in 20 unique locations which is
is very
significant also included in that um
count of 160 unique providers are 44
unique providers who are in Border
community
which are actually um closer
geographically sometimes for our members
to receive services and that is why
we've chosen to include them in the
network so there are 44 unique providers
at 24 unique locations and those are you
know being
used um the county breakdown to the
right will show you that you know there
are some areas where there are lower
numbers of providers and we are actively
recruiting in those areas um you'll ALS
also see when we talk about the mobile
service events that we're targeting the
areas with the lowest um number of
providers obviously because that's where
the support is needed um the following
pages will show uh the growth that we've
had in the network so going back to
November we were at 147 providers July
we had
131 and then back as we were getting
ready to go in March only 66 so there
has been consistent growth um during the
last 10 months uh recruitment continues
that has never stopped um as well as um
the recruiters are now circling back
with the providers who are already in
network to see if they're at a point in
time where they may be able to increase
the
utilization um in their offices and
hopefully um staffing issues have
improved and they are more able to see
um additional members for
us and then the last um chart shows you
the mobile dental clinics that were
scheduled for the month of February
unfortunately the visit at New London
Hospital had to be postponed into March
just due to um getting everything set
and in place with agreements there but
that has been
rescheduled um the visit last weekend to
lree heal lampre healthc care was very
successful 26 members were treated um in
the two days that they were there um and
then there are additional clinics coming
up this weekend I do not have the March
schedule as yet um they really don't
like to share that with us until they
have things
solidified um all of these events are
well uh received um solve air Health who
runs the mobile clinics has a dedicated
phone line um for individuals to call to
make appointments for each of the
clinics so that is One telephone number
um and they do not have to you know they
can simply ask when is the next event at
such and such a location and they're
able to book appointments in advance and
Sol a healthare is also keeping waiting
lists because um you know as happens
people do cancel appointments they want
to have a waiting list to go to so that
the time that they are in those
locations is well used so they do um use
waiting lists uh to make sure that their
schedule is
full um March visits are coming up as I
said in chesher County Sullivan County
and also out on the Sea Coast and we are
continuing to work on a weekly basis
looking at where are we finding that
there are needs um we are making
connections with people across the state
who feel that they may be in an area
that mobile services would work well for
and so um it's an everchanging schedule
these events are not meant to be oneand
done they are meant to be um a
consistent source of care for the folks
who are in those areas and so there are
repeat visits back to the same locations
on a regular basis to make sure that
there is some continuity for
care um and then you know we have some
upcoming reporting uh targeting for May
uh where we'll look at service
statistics and other Milestones um and
then June will be some financial
reporting that we can do once we have um
at you know actually concluded one solid
year of um function so I'll be happy to
answer any questions question from the
chair uh the continued growth of
providers from 66 to 131 147 160 um do
you have some people in the pipeline
that aren't officially providers yet but
they're looking like they're going to be
yes we and I'm thank you for bringing
that up um as we speak there's probably
somewhere between four to six um
providers who are in credentialing and
so you know we are seeing changes on a
weekly basis um that you know there's
always someone in the pipeline could you
speak to the question of how many if any
have signed on and then chosen not to
continue I don't have an absolute answer
I can't give you a number today there
there have been a few but I if you would
like I can certainly find out exactly
how I'm a liberal arts guy a few is my
language okay thank
you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair this is more
of a comment than it is a question I
just wanted to take a moment to
recognize Mr lion and Dr Finn um we are
looking at something in clarem for the
San County Market I've met with a city
manager to secure locations we have
identified two or three locations that
are potential so we'll definitely want
to get back to you about that but I also
want to recognize the work you folks are
doing thank you thank you very much I
appreciate your help and this is what
we're looking for you know community
members who can step up and really help
to guide us uh as to what would be good
locations so thank
you representative Edwards um thank you
Mr chair I it feels like I have about
five questions let's take them one at a
time all right so um just going through
your slide deck um on the on the first
slide with the bar graphs um th this
this triggers in my mind uh the the
conversations that we had around um the
the challenges we would have if patients
became no shows or were late and uh and
that that could really
undermine um the satisfaction action
with the the provider satisfaction with
the program and we talked about some
things to
reduce um no shows and so it so this bar
graph makes me wonder uh if we have data
on no shows uh that might be an
interesting thing to track I don't know
if you track it but I I I'm curious
about it we do have a a way to track it
um that is not something specifically on
any of our metrics that we do on a
regular basis but I can certainly um
prepare something for you all to show I
mean you know part of the way that we're
dealing with this for example with the
mobile events they do con confirm
appointments the day before and they use
text voicemail you know whatever method
um and so I think that is very helpful
um the other thing is that uh the
dentists are reporting to D Quest when
there are late cancellations and no
shows and they are tracking that um I
think that we have noticed that having
the transportation available um has
helped I think that is is definitely
doing what we anticipated that it would
do that's one less reason why someone
might cancel an appointment and then the
other thing is that there is the Care
Management piece so the what management
Care Management okay so if a dental
office reports say you know two or three
times the same person is either you know
late cancelled late or not shown dqu is
reaching out with their care managers
and having a conversation with those
individuals to try to get at the reason
why they have had you know multiple
issues with getting to an appointment
and to try to bring some type of
resolution because you know we not only
want the members to get the care they
need we want to make sure that the
provider's time is used efficiently
right follow up follow up is this two or
three this is we're still on we're about
to do one B now follow one okay I'm on
one B got it so um got that so obviously
we're not uh uh reimbursing a tremendous
amount and so there's already some um
self-sacrifice by the providers taking
these patients because the reimbursement
is pretty low it the no-show aspect of
it can really under mind the
sustainability of the program and so I I
just thought you you know for that
reason alone it may be worth track and
that that's me commenting on what you
just said you actually if I can sort of
digress slightly to address um rates we
have been working with our actuaries to
do an analysis to really see where New
Hampshire Medicaid adult Dental fee
schedule sits Now versus the commercial
market and uh we're basically
reimbursing at approximately 78% of
commercial rates that's way too
much were we were at we were at 48%
prior to the rate increases okay good
that's not 72 72% I'm sorry not 7 see
you've already got her down six more
okay so that completes one but uh so the
second one gets into uh and it's related
to the first one and
are we anticipating doing any provider
surveys where we kind of randomly
anonymously find out what their
satisfaction with this this program is
uh maybe we can identify issues ahead of
time to remediate before they're they a
problem um yes that is actually um part
of the contract there is there is a
survey of providers as well as members
because again we want to see both sides
out outstanding and that okay so uh I'm
on page three and I'm I'm looking at
this page and I think last month or
whenever I was here with you last we
looked at this table to the right and uh
there was some discussion about possibly
using a management by exception
technique to where you could highlight
or color or put an arrow next to uh any
areas any Geographic traff areas that
you are are are considering problematic
you know that sometimes people use this
red yellow green technique to indicate
the greens are okay the reds are a
problem I mean I I I just would like to
see how we're doing and and with that
Geographic breakdown I'd be curious uh
about specialty shortages I I I see that
this chart has broken down into like
general dentistry and oral surgery is
there is there like a third or fourth
specialty you're keeping an eye on like
I I don't know where orthodonics is is
that that's oral children's benefit
there is no that's the children's
benefit there's no Orthodontics included
for the adult Dental benefit I thought
for the old people we we had
Orthodontics that we authorized in hp2
well denture we have Dentures orth
Orthodontics is the tooth movement you
know braces okay so that we cover up to
age 21 so that's and the children's
benefit um the way this benefit is set
up today yeah um oral surgeons are
really the only specialty that we are
enrolling um we do not cover root canals
so there are no idonis that are included
and we have very limited
periodontal um Services there are
services that can be covered by um
dental hygienist so we don't we don't
have enrollments for periodontis should
that ever change in the benefit you know
the coverage should ever change then we
would start to track those
Specialties follow up follow up to three
okay so so under the management by
exception uh principle if we if I could
see some sort of geographic where we
concerned and if you have specialty
concerns you highlight those I I I think
you know there's there's been some
issues with I will be happy to update
this graph and share that with the
committee okay um it's not it's not
obviously urgent I wouldn't go back and
re-engineer your this document it will
not take very long to do that I'd be
happy to do so and then followup follow
this followup I'm getting close to five
oh we ski yeah so uh CU I crammed two
into one so to beat your buzzer we
appreciate that um okay on slide
seven um so I love the concept of these
mobile dental clinics okay but the
business guy in me H looks at this and I
can't help but Wonder uh what a profit
and loss on the mobile van approach
would look like and who's covering you
know the operating costs uh of the van
and and later in a budget cycle if it's
the state that's paying for all these
mobile we have a lot of different mobile
things and and and and and I've always
I've always kind of uh um been a little
bit concerned about how these mobile
capabilities are spread in a stove pip
like manner throughout the DHHS budget
and this one's important but to are you
keeping track of these as a as a these
mobile services are part of the contract
that the state holds with nor Northeast
Delta Dental and then their
subcontractor Dent Quest so it's
included in that that contract it's not
outside of that so we don't have our own
Fleet that we're sending no we don't uh
and I have to say solare healthc care
has probably one of the most outstanding
fleets of mobile services and not just
for for dental in other states they
provide other mobile services and part
of what goes into the planning for these
events and what makes it a little bit
more difficult than just you know
putting names and places down on
calendar is that they are strategically
looking at where do we have the truck
this week where are we going to next
week and how can we also start to expand
the number of days that we're doing
services for that reason obviously they
have to look at their bottom line that
they're not you know going from the
north to the south and east to the west
and any way haphazardly so so we've been
working together for a year and a half
and I just want to say how how how much
I've appreciated you building this
program and executing it so well and I
appreciate your questions here today
thank or your answers my I love my
questions but I really liked your
answers we appreciate your support we
couldn't we couldn't be here today
without all of you supporting this so
thank you all right representative
Weber thank you Mr chair uh going back
to page number three for those of us on
the west
coast um I'm I'm looking at the five
locations in chesher but I'm also
noticing the
um what was it eight locations in
Windsor County Vermont and I'm wondering
where those are because as I think about
Windsor County Vermont I'm trying to
figure out how it has more Dental
locations than we do uh but I I where
are those if you know and if you don't
know if you could just send them in that
would be really helpful I don't off hand
I will absolutely um send those
representative
Merchant
on page
two when you talk about claims
paid you talked about upper dentures and
lower Dentures would that be one claim
I'm trying to get to is that's two
claims how do we separate the claims
from Services because if a claim has
multiple services in it or is each claim
a separate service for um a service such
as a denture there is only one claim
that comes in even though there could be
five or six visits to accomplish that
and there's a very there's a unique code
for each type of prosthesis and so we
are able to pull that data so that's how
we arrived at that number so I follow up
so I understand this
correctly there's the visit and a claim
could actually include multiple visits
correct so this doesn't attract visits
this tracks CL for a Ure and each
insurer has their own there are some
insurers that say you can send in a in
the claim the day that you do the first
visit others do not want to claim until
the prosthesis has been delivered thank
you so you're
welcome uh yes uh follow up please on
and did I understand correctly that you
said earlier that uh upper and lower
Dentures are two claims so what we have
delivered to date are 26 separate
correct uppers or lowers so maybe 13
people but maybe more and there could be
some partials in there know but we we
take out it just it just gives me a
clearer idea of the scope of what we've
managed so thank you very much for that
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chairman um I
I I notice and and I I know the answer I
think um in looking at page two in the
bar graph um there were more claim is
paid each month the member seen and I'm
assuming that's because of the B billing
cycle and paying for previous months um
what's the turnaround time if if I may
ask a two-part question what's the
turnaround time uh once you once the
state is build and the payment goes out
is it like a 30-day cycle or no it's
actually faster than that um I believe
that dent Quest is processing claims
within a week oh and then you know the
payment cycle I don't know exactly how
that falls but it is relative quick if I
may make a comment that that's a great
incentive for providers to want to do
business with us too so great thank you
agreed follow up on
this so now I'm wondering if I have um I
was making an assumption on that graph
that uh the numbers seen in the claims
paid that the reason that the claims
paid were larger was that some members
had been seen for two different
procedures corre is that why that is
correct that's the other thing other
than the lag that we were already
talking about now someone who's coming
in say their first visit you know
February 1st could have been for an exam
X-rays and cleaning they come back two
weeks later have some fillings done
those are going to be two distinct
different claims so great yeah that's
what I was thinking it meant but I
wasn't sure I think I know the answer to
this but this will set up question um
under County breakdowns these are New
Hampshire citizens but their provider is
across the border yes right and
comparing the since I'm from
Massachusetts and even moving here
didn't get far north of the Border um
I'm noticing of course a lot of people
in Middle sex County Massachusetts
because simply there's low there's major
population people just south of um Mid
middle well in Middle sex County and
Essex County but when we come to
Worcester County which is very populated
it is not populated on the northern
border in fact middle SE County goes
this way so you don't start being in
Worcester County until you're in um
Ashburnham and then off to winchington
and those are low population places in
Massachusetts AB buding new whip switch
New Hampshire and low population places
there which is why the big disparity
between the numbers in Massachusetts
seen people exactly and as you brought
up you know middle sex people can get
495 and then right off of there for
visit so it is for folks who live in the
southern part of the state that is
accessible good thank you any other
questions thank you so much we'll see
you soon thank you very much keep it up
right and the chair
recognizes uh Christine santinello to
substitute insute from Melissa Hardy uh
on the DD ABD weightless quarterly
report did you want the sorry there's
Henry Lipman still there if you you came
getting the hook to do well you know
we've been so wanting to see Dr Finny
yes that I'm sorry that's okay um I'm
I'm not offended that's what you're
talking about yes um I also have um if
you if you're interested uh a financial
piece on on granted advantage
um that I didn't send out in advance it
just got finished last night but uh if
you if you have room for that or I can
just make this short
too why don't we make it short and make
us beg you for more and then send us
stuff okay email okay sure so um and I
also apologize that I in the rush of
getting things out on time I missed
putting page numbers on here so I'm
going to go slow to make sure I don't
lose anybody on on that end but you got
us Mr ch's business card so thank you
did and and if you look on your PDF
you'll see the page numbers uh on the in
the pdf version you should also have uh
Sarah's presentation in a PDF format
that gives you colorcoded stuff so a
little easier to look at um but um so in
terms of uh the overall enrollment um as
of uh this past Monday um we stood you
know a combined enrollment at
individuals which um is still a bit
above where we were in March of 2020 um
and uh you know we have through the
unwind um enrollment has gone down um
almost uh 68,000 almost 68,500
684936382 higher than I thought it was
going to be but I think it may be a
function of how we structured the unwind
when we come up again to the beginning
of a year which will be you know April 1
you know I think more of the granted
Advantage people were earlier in the
unwind so we may see that the other
phenomena phenomena I am seeing is that
um with people who have disabilities um
that have not yet been certified by
either Social Security or by the
department that granted Advantage um is
a stopping point what uh until their say
waiver or disability determination is
done so I think we're seeing a little
bit more of that in terms of our
enrollment
um uh you know a couple of uh things
that um aren't on this page and aren't
necessarily in the deck that I'd like to
just um speak to is um you know just
sort of application processing in terms
of from a standpoint um later in the
deck you'll see a slide that's on exp
parte which means that the state has
enough um information to process it on
it on its own um and um one of the
things that we've been analyzing is what
uh what we've been able to do in the
more complicated areas of expart the the
people who have to Pro proove income and
you know might have a trust or whatever
you and that um I think we've seen um in
the Home and Community Based area that
last few months we've had almost 72% of
the Home and Community Based um
applications we have enough information
to process on which means a higher level
of retention and I'll show you the
retention that we've seen more recently
and in the nursing facility area it's
it's almost
48% um so I think there's some good
progress being made there we still are a
bit challenge I think right now in terms
of the fact that the unwind was
structured to you know do more of the
more difficult one once towards the end
so that we had enough experience and
that these people were more likely to
retain
coverage um the next uh slide is just a
a trend and um not really trying to make
a point here but just trying to share a
longer term Trend in enrollment uh with
respect to uh adults with
disabilities and then the slide after
that is titled trended disabled children
in home Home Care again I think that you
know well before the unwind going back
to 15 we've seen a slope and later on
you'll also see some slides about what's
you know New Hampshire's child
population is lower than it was uh over
time you see that in school enrollment
as well um the the next slide actually
which has a number on it now Slide Five
um is uh the uh what's happened with the
children again the was a wellestablished
trend pre pandemic um uh if you go back
to the first slide that we looked at um
on enrollment you'll see that I think in
a lot of categories declines are sort of
stabilizing and we're seeing a slight
increase part of that for children is
going to be that effective gener one
children now um under 19 years of age
have a year of continuous enrollment
irrespective of of changes and
circumstances we also have the
postpartum coverage that was adopted by
the legislature which women now who have
more than 60 days they now have a year
for that and then uh the third one that
was approved was um uh people who are
legally residing the mothers and and
children there so that's not a very big
group but but the first two are larger
uh children in particular um slide six
uh has uh
you know just a trend in in children um
shown that we pulled from some
statistics there just to back up a
little bit of the discussion earlier um
you know a positive sign I see is that
um on slide seven is that there are
fewer people with that are below the
300% of poverty New Hampshire has the
fifth highest meaning the fifth most
generous um eligibility level for
children uh we go up to 323 per of
poverty um and national average is like
2117 um so you know I think that New
Hampshire has always prioritized
children um in in Medicaid coverage that
goes you know long before my
time um and also you know looking at
slide eight this is just looking at 400%
where these you know we're seeing an
increase in our state population of
people with higher incomes bouncing out
of the you know the the pandemic
period um slide SL nine um is just
basically what we describe as our um
unwind strategy and I won't go over this
slide in detail but um slide
10 is a a chart or dashboard for what we
call the protected population this was
the original almost 104,000 people that
had U because of the public health
emergency had continuous coverage some
as long as three years um and that if
you look on the far right at top the
remaining future redes redeterminations
to be done in this group is only 102 um
so we're we're pretty much done um with
that and you can see on the bottom left
the number one reason for closure was
over income um followed by failed to
redetermined if you you would like to to
see that um
on page 11 I which is the percentage
page i' point out that for for
individuals who um didn't redetermining
the month they were due that we see a
lot of them coming back within 30 days
um some 60 and up to 90 we actually
allow up to 120 days without having to
file a new application as a part of the
flexibility um the on slide 12 is the
the children um and there you can see we
completely worked through the protected
population
there again on the bottom left uh income
was the number one reason that children
did not retain
coverage um the next slide 13 is the
longterm care um disabled that's again
we try to go slower with this group and
we're still going slow because these
people need a lot more time and help to
to get through the process because often
times if you're dealing with was a
family member who might have Alzheimer's
or something that you know that the
family has to to to help and sometimes
you know we do need documentation that's
hard to get to um again number one
reason for for not retaining coverage is
is
income um I think this following slide
where I lost my page number which I
think is slide 14 by count um is the
analysis we did based on what was in the
news back a few months where New
Hampshire was they talked about children
losing coverage in New Hampshire and we
did um they Define children as between
zero and 23 as the federal government
did the reason they did that is because
certain kids aged out of being a kid
during that time and also some um like
foster care have coverage longer so but
what we looked at here was um you know
using the same analytic framework that
the the federal government did is uh we
broke it down between the protected and
nonprotected but of the the nonprotected
which uh the the general this is the
first time they're coming up for re
redetermination um
84.7% retain coverage um
1.8% um found coverage because maybe
they were 19 now could get go to granted
Advantage uh 3% went to other and
13.3% closed
and for those that Clos the number one
reason again was
income um when you look at the protected
population these are individuals that
have been protected for up to three
years that you know 48.2% of those
closed again when you look at the number
one reason its income um almost half is
just income related you know 13.3% was
either they weren't requesting or that
they had a change in circumstances and
where family income may change um one
house one person household adult versus
a two person adult would be an example
um those a number that were
categorically un eligible as well but I
think the takeaway from this slide are
two things is one that every every
individual on this
slide could we stop that for a question
on this particular slide
please I just wanted to make sure I was
understanding the term remained to
children so have we is is the point of
calling them remain
children reflecting the fact that kids
who simply aged out of being eligible
are not included in this no this would
be anybody as of March 1st of
2023 which was the month that the unwind
started if you will okay that that
that's a fixed population looking at
where they stood um as of this analysis
was as of December that this was the
outcome for all these individuals so
okay so remain children is just a term
for the kids who started in started the
starting number right and and so this
also includes individuals who may be 23
right I understand the B the point about
the the definition of what a child was I
just the term remained children are two
words that I'm having trouble putting
together and making sense of so maybe if
I could restate it is that as of March 1
of
2023 yep everybody on this page was
either was between Zer and 23 years of
age okay thank you very much that helps
um and the other thing on WE we've done
you know a lot of Outreach efforts but
we made a special effort um to call
every single person who failed to
redetermined to finish their
redetermination uh made attempts either
through the department or the MOs or um
we provided list to Providers um
you know we're also working with the
mental health centers now in terms of
what more we can do to to help them um
they've been hit in two ways one they
have a challenging population when they
have a severe mental illness the second
is a lot of the In-N-Out Medicaid that
had continuous coverage for three years
now have to approve their every month
could I ask a followup followup um so if
I were looking for the numbers of the
individuals who aged out based on that
up to 23 would that categorically would
they come up under categorically
ineligible now or where are the numbers
of the kids who simply aged out here so
I'd have to give you something different
this was just looking at a the cohort as
of March 1 who fit into that category
but we do have that you um we do have
that information I could do a followup
for you on
that okay so now I'm really confused
because
I had assumed that this
was overtime but what this is is just a
snapshot SN on that day and what had
happened up to that day correct okay I'm
sorry I was thinking about it going
forward so all is much clearer now thank
you we were trying to line up our
analysis with the fed's analysis to of
course representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair and thank you Miss lippin for
taking the
question
under Granite advantage and also looking
at remain
children help me understand I guess I
was misunderstanding
potentially aren't all people who are in
Medicaid under granded advantage or do
we have separate buckets between those
who are in granted Advantage versus the
traditional Medicaid Program so there
are a lot of different eligibility
categories so children would typically
be in children's Med you can't be in
granted Advantage if you're um under 19
years of age granted Advantage is 19 to
64 granted Advantage is just a um an
adult it's it's a I guess the term of
art is
um adults that are are uh income only
based their eligibility based on their
income followup
followup in regards to the Granite
Advantage then it's adult program only
it's not for children correct so
therefore if somebody's in a age 19 or
less or under 19 do they go for the
traditional Medicaid Program um FIFA
service versus a Medicaid HMO so um
we're predominantly a manag Managed Care
State almost 90 99% 98 we have only
about 2,000 individuals that are for
have some basis to not be included in
Managed Care um
that are special populations by federal
designation but basically children
typically would get their eligibility in
the children's categories either um
low-income children or chip children
which are allows the the income of the
the child's family to go up to 323 per
of
poverty I'm sorry I need to go back one
more time okay one more time I'm really
sorry but the more I look at this chart
the more bewildered I get because what
it says at the top is the chart below
illustrates the number of children that
were eligible in Medicaid at the
beginning of their unwind and their
current status
yes and then there is a an
asterisk um which says statuses of 28
2024 yes
so we looked at that so the whole thing
is their status yes if you were out so
the stat it's not a so it's not a
snapshot as of March 1st it's where the
March first people are now yes you got
it right okay I'm sorry if that wasn't
clear no no no no no I I think I'm being
particularly fuzzy it's been a long week
we're going to need to pick up the pace
a little bit because of several other
agenda items I'll take 30 seconds to
finish the rest that'll be wonderful
page 15 is just the positive trend in X
parte renewal rates um I'll skip page 16
because it's just basically um and I'll
just jump you ahead to
uh page what would be page 17 CMS
reporting and closure reasons cumulative
um and I'm G to just once you find that
page I'm just going to go one more and
just talk about what happened in January
um and then I'll stop talking um so the
reporting here if you will the flesh
tone color is the percentage of people
um both protected and regular renewals
that retained coverage in January and
basically we saw record retention of
coverage at 94% overall 94 um and you
can see that
uh um
if you go back and look at other slides
in this deck that you know we've we've
as we've gone through the unwind as
expected that we the people we most
likely expected to retain coverage we
put them towards the back because it
made sense to not try to to uh take take
them on if you will until after um after
we had done the people that we knew were
likely not to be eligible um and I'll
stop there I have U some Financial
material I can leave with you and also
send to you or just send it to you if
that's your
preference it's a long-term snapshot on
the finances if you've got written
materials uh please uh if you would give
them to uh representative Murphy and
we'll pass them around
and you
may um o okay so um I I want to ask you
about adult eligibility for Medicaid and
I got four categories I want to ask you
about okay uh and uh I'll take a yes or
a no and if you can't answer it in a yes
or a no we can talk about it offline to
save time okay um under the refugee
resettlement program I understand that
those
refugees uh are uh covered by
Medicaid and any Medicaid costs are
reimbursable by the federal government
the State Medicaid cost is that is that
is that a yes or a no it's more
complicated than a yes or no okay so so
we'll we'll talk offline uh how about
those with um a green card who are here
and have a green card are are they
eligible for Medicaid after five year
waiting period five years y but there's
also a little bit of uh something I
could talk to you specialty on that too
okay how about those individuals who are
in the country uh seeking political
Asylum and they're awaiting a
hearing generally no generally no like
there is emergency Medicaid of someone
yeah yeah we have to help everyone that
shows up in the ER I get that and so so
this last category I assume is kind of
the same we have to help them in the ERS
because it's a compassionate thing to do
but those individuals that are in the
country without any federal
documentation yeah I I think that falls
into generally emergency Medicaid but
there could be some finer points there
that we should talk about okay I I
really want to understand this better so
can I set up a meeting with you yes I
would include someone from the
eligibility area as well as the Medicaid
subject matter expert on this because it
is a is a complicated area yeah uh thank
you and might you boil it down to a
onepage answer for the rest of us please
I'll try I'm I'm not as smart as mrman
but I'll try that's why I only gave you
one
page thank
you good to see you as always now the DD
and ABD waight list quarterly report
associate commissioner Chris Santaniello
and and I am here and I'm Melissa Hardy
was unable to be here so I'm pinch
hitting for her today but um I'm here
joined um with by Jessica Gorton Jessica
is our new bureau chief for the Bureau
of developmental Services she started in
January in this role um she prior to
that um came to the Bureau of
Developmental services in
2018 and prior to that worked as a
family service specialist um for
eligibility under long-term care so Jess
has a lot of experience and we're happy
to have her
here is that your previous Rule and you
got promoted or I I'm I'm I I just don't
know your organizational treat very well
yes have several promotions since um
2004 when I started working at the
bureau excuse me at the department uh
prior to being the bureau chief I was
the administrator of Home and Community
Based waivers and did a fair amount of
work with the three waiver documents as
well as our administrative rules so I
recognize a few faces from jel car I
believe and one of the regular questions
do you have a business card I do not but
I can definitely get in contact inform
okay we give a one month grace period on
that they I believe they're on
order so I'm sorry back to the
organization chart
idea I've been gone quite a lot did I
think miss sanella you you got a
promotion did that open up your position
for um for this woman to take for Jess
to take no no no um I've been associate
commissioner a couple years we um our
former bureau chief Sandy um phoh left
the department in this fall I
is okay and so Miss Miss Hardy is is
still senior he's still the division
director just reports to Melissa and
Melissa is just not able to be here
today all right thanks I just like
knowing the moving
Parts congratulations thank you very
much yes all right thank you all so
there is a handout in front of you go
for viewing the DD ABD and inhome
supports wait list inform information
for quarter 1 and as you review that
information we wanted to point out a few
pieces of um or a few updates data
that's changed and that we collect and
how we report and the report that's in
front of you so first the utilization of
the New Hampshire lead system
historically used by the area agencies
and the Bureau of Developmental services
to track funding requests for
individuals in need of services that
ceased um ceased at the end of fiscal
year 23 so individuals in need of waiver
Services beginning fiscal year 24 this
last July we were able to capture that
data prior to as you may be aware we
typically fund individuals about 90 days
ahead of time uh once July came around
though that information was no longer
available so what you're seeing in front
of you was a manual uh data collection
for the time being as we transition
systems as of July 1st though our area
agencies began using New Hampshire easy
um our information technology system to
represent those ongoing funding
needs also as of July 1st
2023 we have stopped identifying in
including information around folks that
we previously represented as a c or we
also referred to those as
enhancements um these requests are now
submitted as they're needed and they are
reviewed and funded in addition as those
requests come through so no longer a
waiting time period until funds are
distributed to the the other groups that
we refer to as a and
in addition the information in front of
you due to the transfer to the New
Hampshire Easy System the delay reasons
that were previously reported are no
longer reflected within this report and
that's an interim process or an interm
um data metric that's not included as
that would have been because that
information was no longer available we
couldn't automatically transfer that
information so rather than asking our
partners at our area agencies and our
Service Coordination agencies to input
that data manually um we instead focused
on authorizing service authorizations
and ask for the resources to be directed
in those areas um in the future though
that data will continue to come through
as these new requests are being added
that information is also being added in
addition to the funding amount uh any
delay reasons that might present after
someone receives their funding we do
have meetings weekly with our Service
Coordination agencies which also incl
clud our area agency partners who offer
Service Coordination Services where we
talk about what these delay reasons
might be um as you may see on page three
of the report the the number one reasons
are limited capacity of staff and the
workforce short shortage so additionally
we have bi-weekly meetings with service
provider agencies which also include
many of our area agency partners who
offer Direct Services and many other of
our private providers out in the state
where we talk about various issues that
might be impacting service availability
and when Services can begin for
individuals who've been funded so we're
trying to continue communication while
we're working on restoring uh that data
that was previously tracked in New
Hampshire
leads yes and that is all manually
tabulated on both ends manually entered
and manually pulled for this time period
until we move to that still again
manually entered with the funding
requests but then we should have that
information available with the
poll representative Weber so am I
correct in thinking that these are
simply the new individuals during the
quarter and that we also have a
significant backup of people from
earlier quarters that are also receiving
either partial or no Services yes I
would say that's accurate folks who have
received the funding but haven't yet
been able to start their services right
at some point it would be useful to know
the global numbers rather than just I
mean the quarter numbers are helpful but
the global numbers would also be useful
thank you representative Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair uh and welcome uh one
of the longstanding questions to your
your counterpart was or your your your
predecessor rather was uh has been uh
the state is obligated to fund 100% of
those that need need DD support um there
has been an issue of not everyone being
able to get those Services because lack
of providers or whatever and so I've
always wanted to know uh what the what
the number is that have been fully
funded but have not yet uh been able to
get the services they need and and maybe
that's you know uh should be broken down
between zero services and partial
services and fully serviced and I I
think this t a couple of these tables a
couple of these tables get close to that
and so that gives me hope that maybe
that we can do this but if if you can
give it to me after a year and a half of
asking for it you would be a hero or a
heroin what you get to pick your pronoun
okay I I think that that is the goal
utilizing New Hampshire easy is to be
able to track that data in a meaningful
way moving forward the the total
universe and not just by quarter and not
based on manual polls and calculation
but to have a systematic way to go
forward and watch that because it really
does speak to Quality access of services
in addition to our obligations and our
responsibilities to fund as well but
really getting to the heart of our folks
getting Services thank you do you have
any statistics or even some good anec
doal stories as to how each Area Agency
believes itself to be fully staffed for
the demands made on it that we could
see yeah I I wouldn't want to speak for
the area agencies but I think similar to
what a lot of our other provider
agencies inclusive of area agencies have
reported um around Staffing concerns and
considerations and trying to make sure
they have as many as many staff
available as necessary to fully support
individuals and to continue to offer
services to new individuals whose needs
might arise and I wouldn't ask you to
speak for for them but I would ask you
to take what they spoke for themselves
to you and collate it so it's all on one
page and I don't have to make 10 phone
calls I I would say that their feeling
would be similar um to our other
provider area excuse me provider
agencies and other service sectors that
you know we certainly are working
through a pretty critical shortage of
Staff within the state it took me a year
and a half for the wellness center that
I supervise to get another family
practice physician and certified
counselor a year and a half so I get it
i' just like to know how bad it is and
is there an area or two where it is much
worse than other places I just want to
kind of a state picture yeah generally
speaking I think in the northern area of
our state we've heard you know different
concerns around Staffing that also tie
to various other things that we've even
heard discussed here by other colleagues
within the department around
transportation and and those concerns
for not just the individuals we support
but also the providers who are offering
those Services um the Western area of
our state as well has has mentioned
similar concerns in that area uh for
similar reasons and then of course other
things other areas that we're looking to
address systematically or systemically
rather um we have other opportunities
too that we're excited about and I think
associate commissioner santinello would
be able to speak to those as well yeah I
think um one of the things the
department put out
in
it over the summer early fall was um
funding for Home and Community Based
Workforce initiatives and so it was
helping um providers to either come up
with retention strategies recruitment
strategies and so we issued about 27
contracts and we actually are going to
reissue that um request for Grant Awards
to really help some of the providers
come up with Creative Solutions to
assist them so we'll be getting some
data from that as
well
good representative
McDonald thank you Mr
chairman uh when I was on the Department
New Hampshire easy was most known for
the the to make it possible to apply
online for service for an
individual uh I get the impression
obviously with more more than an
impression um it's being used for just
about everything for uh any needs uh
from agencies and individuals now it's
been expanded dramatically is that fair
to say yes moving that information into
one at a glance system where individuals
can access information not only about
their Medicaid Eligibility but also
those extended services or those waiver
services that they may have we really
think is a value ad maybe about 10 a
little less than 10 years ago our fourth
Home and Community Based 1915 sea waiver
also integrated into New Hampshire easy
with quite a bit of success so we we
wanted to follow that model and make
sure it was consistent across all four
of the the Seas as we call them the sea
wavers followup uh and individuals are
still able to apply through New
Hampshire easy for benefits yes okay
thank you you're
welcome thank you for your report thank
you very much and this is just a little
message to attorney um Edward uh
Williams That's Edwards your Williams
this wonderful thing that you uh come up
with periodically a contact list for
constituent referrals soon to be uh well
we we dealt with Dr hen's phone number
error but the uh David chy uh who I have
a card for and Jessica Gorton who's
going to give me a card and all of that
and the next issue of this is coming out
real soon right
thank
you and thank you for your
presentation Jess has one more agenda
item underneath this she'll go fast
representative Edwards has one more and
we don't have enough but maybe if you
can get Coy and
share we have
more just
one thank you so the report being passed
around in front of you goes over our
pilot project we're all all sit now I
think and we were hoping to give a
update to this to this committee so I'll
be brief and you know C it certainly
take any questions after so our pilot
program aimed at um assisting
individuals between the ages of 18 and
21 could you get closer to the mic yes
sorry is that better that is okay so our
pilot program aimed at assisting
individuals ages 18 to 21 Who are
ineligible for the developmental
disabilities waiver because they're
still in school um as you all may recall
there was quite a gap in our system to
be able to fund those folks so as of
this time um we are currently supporting
six individuals using that pilot program
funding um four of those individuals are
receiving residential services and two
of those individuals receiving um
enhancements to their current inhome
supports waiver so that um is a waiver
that is capped at $35,000 per year so
the pilot program is enabling them to
receive the additional funding that
would help to support them to remain
living at home with their
families um total cost of services
provided so far is around 545 just shy
of
$546,000 so it's been a great help um 12
people have applied so far and 11 have
been
approved and there was one denial that
was determined um as the local
educational Authority was financially
responsible so the the denial was really
because there was another funding source
that was available
representative
Weber there are 11 who were approved and
six who were actually receiving Services
what's happening with the other five we
have five individuals who have been
approved and they're currently looking
to receive Services through what we call
an enhanced Family Care model where they
would move in with a a family who would
provide care to them within a family
home okay thank you
welcome representative Ed Edwards uh
thank you Mr chair um so so this number
545,000 jumps out at me for six
individuals and I I just want to know
what all is is included in this 545 is
that any employee salaries or anything
is this like a fully loaded cost or is
this just services that would cover the
full cost of services so the provider
their staff their operational expenses
um whoever that service provider might
be to offer those
services so in summary this is this is
just for services being provided to
these six people it does not include
agency salaries or anything uh salaries
for the providers but not for any not
providers for the for
the for the agency for DHHS oh excuse me
no it so I'm just I'm because it just
seems like a really high number yes
because so much of it is for residential
services those do tend to be quite
costly could Mr chair could okay we've
got a time crunch so one more question
this is a request I I I'd like a a
breakdown of that 545 just to
know per of time that's just a big
number we can absolutely provide that
yes okay uh now we are going to move on
to the last item thank you so much for
coming and this is um Senate Bill 118 of
2019 child fatality Review Committee
annual report with Dr Mark
Clement and Ronda
seagull oh look at those nice
handouts thank you
and while we're do getting ready for
this if Christa Morris if you could hang
around a little bit after this meeting
for a few minutes could you do that yeah
and also you I got something I need to
talk to the three of us about together
the third being Williams no Christa
Morris okay thank
you good morning hey good morning my
name is Mark Clement um I'm Co chair of
the committee of been child psychologist
the retired ameriti faculty from Colby
Sawyer college and I still teach
parttime at New England College I think
because of the time
crunch I won't go through my little talk
here but I just want to mention uh three
things or three general principles about
the committee and how we function in our
meetings uh first and
foremost uh one of the major
responsibilities is
confidentiality okay every member signs
a confidentiality agreement that
prohibits them from sharing any
information discussed in the review and
any non-member who comes to the meeting
to share information about the death for
example a police officer who might have
investigated the death is also required
to sign a confidentiality
agreement the second thing I think you
need to know is that we are not an
investigative body we take information
that's brought to the committee by
individuals and agencies that have to
share about the death and lastly we do
not review any deaths that are presently
in litigation or have the possibility of
future litigation this is our guidance
from the Attorney General's office and
after all litigation and appeals have
been completed we would have the
opportunity to review uh those
debts so I think with that said um again
I I won't go through all of my notes
because I know we have a time crunch
here and I know you probably have some
questions so if Ronda if you have
anything you want to add
um sure I'm Rhonda seagull we've met uh
several times before I'm the uh section
head for the maternal and child health
section under which um the oversight of
child fatality Review Committee um sits
I am also a legislated member of uh
child fatality review it is a legislated
committee um I do want to say that the
backbone of any fatality review uh
particularly child fatality review are
the recommendations that are discussed
um at the end um of the committee um
that is uh the reason that we exist um
the recommendations are to hopefully
prevent uh future deaths um the report
that you have in front of you is about
State fiscal year 23 we do not um review
all of the child deaths in the state and
we pick deaths based on um data uh what
the data is showing us the medical
examiners office um Etc so for that year
we focused in on Motor Vehicle crashes
and other land transport such as Farm
vehicles um we focused on overdose St uh
deaths and as well as fire so one of the
things that um happens at our review
meetings is that uh our c colleagues
from across the state uh talk to us
about the things they are doing so for
instance the Fire Marshal's Office uh
presents the data before the meeting and
presents um the prevention activities
that they're involved with that they
lead and they collaborate on um which
helps to inform our recommendations
afterwards um I do want to say that we
uh have initiated a recommendations uh
work Group which is a separate work work
Group which looks at the recommendations
takes what people say um and then um
processes that uh through the lens of
are these recommendations feasible uh
can we pay for them um will they work in
New Hampshire uh what is done in Vermont
it will not necessarily work in uh New
Hampshire um as well as you know does
the community support it who is a
champion if there is a recommendation
uh without a champion uh that
recommendation won't will uh not be
likely
implemented and uh uh the last is does
it have a basis in um in in in science
has this evidence or has this um
intervention you know smoke alarms uh
yes they do uh reduce the uh incidence
of of fire deaths um so I just want to
uh bring your attention to some of the
recommendations from State fiscal year
23 uh which include uh supporting uh uh
parental uh uh the parental role of um
teens uh with their driving habits um
parents have an outsize role at that
table um as myself having four children
who now are a decade ahead of having
driven you know you have to have a
certain amount of hour
uh to drive with them um you know this
includes the support of affordable
driver education uh that parents can pay
for and plenty of practice time uh
social media is always almost one of our
recommendations for uh any of the desks
that we look at um uh social media
obviously is is is um is the way that
people communicate now um we also uh
continue to support uh uh access to data
to guide our interventions and reviews
including the youth risk behavior
survey um which tells us a lot about our
Adolescence in the state um this
particular talking about overdose you
hear lockboxes when you uh think about
Firearms but lock boxes are also a
proven intervention uh for um uh
limiting exposure to uh uh medications
and other things that children might get
into and then the promotion of fire
safety um education and all the
wonderful things that colleagues across
the state are doing um like the office
of Highway Safety the injury prevention
center around uh you know teen driving
initiatives uh motor vehicle crashes
continue to be uh the leading cause of
death amongst uh New Hampshire's
children uh 1 through 21 years of age
with um overdose deaths a close
second um Dr Clement and I are available
for any questions that you may
have Dr
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for the the report here um I always
find this report fascinating because of
the numbers that just are starkly quite
large in some areas and one of the
questions I had was on page eight you
talk about newborn affected
complications of placenta cord in
membranes I'm sorry on page eight eight
yeah uh natural causes of infant death
so it's 11% 21 um
newborns complications of
placenta oh with with uh uh yes so
natural causes of death continue to be
the leading cause of death for for for
babies for infants under one yes thank
you my question was uh do you know where
these newborns had this complication are
these in hospital home births where did
these complications how do you break
that down uh when you're talking about
newborns affected by complications
placenta cord and membranes right so
basically at the time of birth you know
where do they occur I would have to look
further into the data okay thank you the
other question I have if I may on page
eight um but I suspect that I mean most
of our births in the state happen uh at
the at uh birthing hospitals not all but
I need to look at
that I just find that to be a fairly
High number they are in hospital births
that's all um on page nine the number of
suicides is 168 2% which doesn't
surprise me I guess as far as the number
goes what I am surprised is that the
method of
suicide over nearly half of them a
Suffocation nearly half of them of the
suicides are listed as Suffocation yes I
mean that is uh
uh if you were so the state comes out uh
the state Suicide Prevention Council of
which um Health and Human Services um
also has administrative support over not
my section but um Behavioral Health um
comes out with a suicide annual report
that's broken down even further in terms
of um ages um Suffocation uh generally
with with the younger teens uh um
there's male female distinction Firearms
is usually with older uh older teens so
yes does that answer your question no
but I just didn't want to get into the
details I can find that out I can talk
to you later about that okay okay thank
you yeah more yeah yeah
asfixiation yes oh if if you mind um my
my question is that that seems to me a
very high number in a very difficult
methodology of suicide and I'm just
curious as to how that occurs are you
aware of how that occurs or how that
occurs yeah Suffocation yeah in terms of
hang most of them are are hanging death
so that's that's is that what the
question that's I was going with because
yes that's where I was going with that
question thank you because I you're
welcome and we've seen uh access to
things that you would not think
necessarily to put away um dog colors uh
I mean leashes uh and the reason that
question is that number is so high to me
is because in the Press I hear all the
time about suicide by Firearms suicide
by uh drug overdo but I do not hear the
leading cause is listed as Suffocation I
just don't hear that that's all thank
you for clarifying that for
me people yes as yes representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you for taking the question is
there
any
way to take this information
and correlate that over to what's going
on with the children trying to find room
in psychiatrical care in other words I'm
trying to get to is that we have heard
earlier at least I did about the
challenges we have trying to find a way
to help some of the folks get the
treatment they need in a psychiatrical
situation or a bed if you will in the
hospital is there any correlation
between that and what's going on here
with suicide what's happening because if
we have suicide going on is it because
they couldn't get into a facility to
help them with their care they need to
prevent it or is that something I'm just
going up into a rabbit hole uh no I
think uh we hope to see that over the
years um uh the director of the or the
bureau chief for uh children's
Behavioral Health has presented to us on
all the things that uh the Deputy
Commissioner talked about this morning
and um I don't know
Marissa if you want
to um I would say it's um there's
obviously relationship in that uh
impatient psychiatric care is is
critical for youth who are who may not
be safe um and pose a risk to sell for
others um however if you look at the
literature like impatient psychiatric
hospitalization at a population level
isn't generally a way that has ever been
proven to reduce suicide it's very
important for many reasons in including
keeping people safe and getting them
appropriate psychiatric care but um more
of the efforts that have been talked
about by child fatality around things
like lethal means reduction um and um
more uh early interventions are
generally seen as the efficacious
methods for reducing suicide across the
population any further questions uh
representative King
thank you um Mr chairman and thank you
for taking this question I
um I was wondering is is there a way of
breaking down your numbers I'm looking
at page five right now and um page I'm
sorry page
five and I'm looking at the suicide
number um uh actually it's under injury
accident hom homicide suicide and uh the
years are 2018 to
20122 and I know in um there's there was
a lot of uh lot of information out there
about suicide going uh going up when
covid hit so I was wondering if there's
a way of breaking that out to say 2020
and 2022 to see if there was a
relationship of uh
isolation um there's always a way of
breaking things down but I um as I
previously mentioned uh there is a uh
annual suicide data report coming out of
the suicide prevention Council and I am
almost 100% positive that it's coming
out soon I don't know Deputy
Commissioner um you know the
department uh will get that to you as
soon as it's uh released I know that uh
the division of Public Health Services
provided
information um to that report just
recently and that is probably the most
um uh uh complex uh look at um suicide
and suicide data in the state okay thank
you you're
welcome thank you for your report thank
you very much you good outline I was
skimming through it while you were doing
that and this is going to make some good
reading tonight I think so hope to see
you again thank you thank you and with
that it's time to adjourn there is no
meeting next month because of too many
conflicts with too many people so um
that means it will not snow on the last
fourth Friday of March for you from the
North country and we will meet in April
and an announcement will be sent out
shortly about that thank you we're
done